STEVEN BAZYL: Hi, everyone.
And welcome to this week's
"Google Developers Live" for
Google Drive.
I'm Steven Bazyl, joined
here with Ali Afshar.
ALI AFSHAR: Hi.
STEVEN BAZYL: And today we are
going to talk about a couple
of tips that you can use to
increase the performance of
your application and your
integration with Drive.
These are going to be a couple
small things, but they are
pretty important and can
actually have a pretty
dramatic impact on how
your apps perform.
Let's start with a really
simple one.
We have in the API a couple of
the different operations, your
standard RESTful API.
And we have a verb for patch.
And for those who don't know
what patch is, it's a way of
doing partial updates for a
resource so you can only send
the modified fields.
Small bit of advice--
don't use it.
It's really simple.
Actually, the way the Drive API
works, you can just do a
regular update on a resource
with sparse fields, and it
will work fine.
Do you know why it actually ends
up being more efficient?
ALI AFSHAR: So I have an idea,
but just to get it correct.
You have files, and then you
only have a few of the values
that you want to
update in the--
STEVEN BAZYL: [LAUGHING]
Sorry.
Sorry, sorry.
I'm just trolling Ali here.
ALI AFSHAR: So you have a file
that you want to update to
Google Drive.
And you've only got some of
the parameters you want to
actually update.
So you've only got the title.
You've only got the
description.
You don't have everything.
Now, that's what patch exists
for is so that you can send
just a few of these.
But actually, in the Drive
API, it doesn't make any
difference.
You may as well update with
an impartial or sparse
file, as you say.
STEVEN BAZYL: Right, and this
actually turns out to be kind
of a small internal
implementation detail for how
patches work because we actually
end up having to
re-read the entry back.
So it actually costs us
a little bit more.
In terms of actual performance,
it's not going to
make a huge difference
for your application.
But it is a lot more
resource-efficient for us if
you just do a regular update.
And I'm glad that we'll have
some GDL bloopers for after.
We're just in a very
giddy mood today.
So anyway, the next one
is batching requests.
So batch is a way that you can
bundle multiple requests
together into a single
API request.
You can use it for all sorts of
things, with the exception
of uploads.
But that aside, you actually
still have a lot of options.
And there's a couple really
good use cases for things,
like if you're listing the
contents of a folder, and you
want to then expand things like
the custom properties or
the ACLs on a file which
require separate calls.
If you have, say, a page of
files, say 20 files for a
page, you can then batch up
the subsequent request to
expand out whatever additional
properties you want.
And actually, it has a nice
benefit in that it does a
couple things for you.
So one is there's a little bit
less overhead in the HTTP
requests, so all the headers
that you would normally send
plus the fact that you're
usually setting up and tearing
down a connection each time.
There's a lot of overhead.
The other one is, while
you can do the
parallel request yourself--
you can certainly do a whole
bunch of basic requests and
then gather up the results--
the batch actually just handles
all that for you.
And this is implemented in our
client libraries in a way that
makes it super easy to do a
whole bunch of parallel
requests together.
ALI AFSHAR: And that's
interesting, because in our
old APIs, if you ever used the
Documents List API, for
example, you could only
batch the same
type of requests together.
So you could say, I only want to
batch 50 Get requests in a
single batch.
But now with our newer Drive
API, you can actually batch
different types of requests.
STEVEN BAZYL: That's
true, right.
You could actually update 20
files all at the same time.
So if you wanted to add a
description or some properties
to a set of files, you can
actually do those very
efficiently.
One catch--
these do actually count as
separate requests from a quota
perspective.
And while you can certainly
do batches of up to 1,000
requests, if you were to try to
do it, you'd actually start
to run into your QPS limits
for an app and for a user.
But still, it's a useful
technique for certain use
cases where you know that you
need to do a whole bunch of
the operations, and you need to
do them roughly at the same
time and do that very quickly.
So another one is
partial updates.
This is something that
we did a blog post
about just last week.
And this actually has probably
the biggest impact on
application, performance, and
your bandwidth utilization.
So one of the things you can
do is, when you're calling
Drive API, you can [? be ?] a
query parameter called Fields,
list which fields that you
would like returned.
And I did some testing on this
just using the common use case
of listing the contents of a
folder and found that you
could actually get about--
for a common use case, about
90% reduction in bandwidth.
And so that's huge.
So it went from something
like 380 K down to 30.
Actually, it was even
less of that.
Throw in gzip compression, then
it goes from 30 K down to
about 7, so it's actually
pretty important.
And I've heard from a few people
in the community that
this actually has a little bit
of a financial impact, for
cases where you're buying
bandwidth and so on.
ALI AFSHAR: I mean, that's
the whole point of this.
Make fewer requests, that's
going to cost you less.
Send less data, that's going
to cost you less.
Receive less data, that's just
going to cost you less.
So I mean, we don't want
you to pay more
money for the stuff.
That's the main thing.
STEVEN BAZYL: And the
nice thing is--
I mentioned gzip compression.
Gzip compression has a cost
in terms of the CPU usage.
We certainly still
encourage it.
But if you are very sensitive to
CPU, then another way that
you can reduce your bandwidth
is by limiting the amount of
data that you send back
in the first place.
There are some upcoming changes
we're working on in
the backend that will actually
make this not just faster from
a bandwidth perspective, but
actually faster from the
amount of time that it takes
to actually execute the
queries, to serialize the
data into a response.
And so over time, this is
just going to get better
and better for users.
ALI AFSHAR: So right now on the
backend, we fetch all the
data and then selectively
send you some back.
And that's the problem there.
STEVEN BAZYL: Exactly.
And just the way things are
stored, it's actually very
time-consuming to go and
assemble all that data.
But now with these hints, we can
do a lot of optimizations
to make sure that we get results
back to you as a
developer a lot faster.
ALI AFSHAR: So if you just want
to list the titles, the
title of the files in a list,
you just ask for the title.
STEVEN BAZYL: Exactly.
If you did that, you'd probably
save about 95% of the
actual data.
It would just be completely
eliminated from the network.
ALI AFSHAR: And to see how
to do that, check out
Steve's blog post.
STEVEN BAZYL: Yeah,
it's really easy.
All the API clients
support it.
And again, it's just
a query parameter.
There's a little bit of an odd
syntax because these are
structured responses.
So if you have nested
collections or some syntax or
how you would enumerate which
collections and which
properties of those
collections.
But this is all documented
pretty well on
developers.google.com.
The last one, which doesn't
necessarily connect back to
performance quite as much, is
just proper error handling.
So there's a couple different
cases for errors.
So some of the common ones, you
get things like, you're
unauthorized.
You may be rate limited, so that
would be a 403 response.
And you also run into occasional
500 errors.
These aren't necessarily things
that you can control.
When you hit a 500, it's usually
some intermittent
error, a timeout, heavy
load on our side.
But how you respond to those
errors can actually have an
impact, particularly in the case
of high-load situations.
So what are some of the
strategies people should use
for retrying on errors?
ALI AFSHAR: So in general,
retry on errors.
I mean, I think that's
a general point.
Because sometimes, as you
mentioned, intermittent errors
and that kind of thing.
But we, the API--
it's a massive distributive
system.
And we kind of expect
you to retry.
STEVEN BAZYL: Right.
But you don't want to just
retry immediately, right?
ALI AFSHAR: No, no, exactly.
STEVEN BAZYL: Because otherwise,
we're just going to
hammer the server, and things
aren't going to improve.
ALI AFSHAR: So as always,
you should use
an exponential backoff.
So try again, try again in an
exponentially increasing
amount of time, add a little
jitter, of course.
And yeah, just do it.
Usually, it will succeed.
And you'll see, if you check
out Stack Overflow,
occasionally people do
get these errors.
And they're fixed just
by retrying.
STEVEN BAZYL: Yeah, exactly.
One thing is, don't--
on that initial retry, make
sure you put in a delay.
It should be at least
a second.
Obviously, if you're doing
things in user time, you don't
want to go too long
of a delay.
But if it's something more
programmatic, you're doing a
background job, you can actually
even back off a
little bit more aggressively
and give the
system time to recover.
And the jitter is actually
really important.
And for those who don't know
this concept of jitter, it's
basically adding in
some randomized
value into that delay.
So if you just did a fixed
exponential backoff, you might
do a delay of 1 second,
then 2 seconds, then 4
seconds, and so on.
The problem is that if you have
a lot of threads doing
this and they all happen to hit
the same error at the same
time, well, they're all going
to retry at the same time.
And you end up in this kind of
wave, the cycle of servers
just getting hammered
by all of these
clients acting in lockstep.
Adding a little bit of
randomization gives those
clients a little bit of time to
differentiate and get on to
a different period for when
they're going to retry and
start to smooth out the traffic
a little bit more.
So a reasonable value
could be maybe 10%.
Just pick a random value and
then add or subtract.
But it'll make things recover a
lot faster if you have those
types of things.
So are there any other things
you can think of that would
help people?
So there's low-level things
like gzip and so on that
people could do.
But those are usually
taken automatically
by the client libraries.
ALI AFSHAR: So those
are the things--
remember batch requests, catch
errors, and retry.
Partial fetch here is really
important, so passing the
fields parameter to just
get back what you want.
And patch sounds like a good
idea, but it's probably better
to just do an update, a partial
update at the time.
But those are our things.
And remember why you do this.
It just saves you bandwidth.
It saves you time.
And sometimes it saves us time,
which obviously isn't
your main concern.
But it just means you get the
requests back quicker, which
is obviously going to be good.
You get better latency
in your application.
So that's good.
STEVEN BAZYL: Yep.
So that's all for this week.
Next week, I am not entirely
sure if we have
our topics set for--
that we may actually skip, but
we'll be back certainly the
week after for our normal
schedule with Apps of the Week
and hopefully, a few guests.
We'll actually be
out next week.
And yeah, until then--
ALI AFSHAR: Thanks very much.
STEVEN BAZYL: --thank
you all for coming.
ALI AFSHAR: Bye.